Sebastian is my dude he always has been
so actually I was the most nervous about
what I saw
see because I love him so much and I
think a lot of people do same right so
when you knew you had to tackle
especially these iconic songs kiss the
girl under the sea what were you most
excited about or maybe even most nervous
about tackling I mean yeah those are the
Bops right like that's what we remember
from the original one so yeah I was
terrified uh really until we started
actually working on it and then Rob made
it so fun and so easy and was so open to
dialing into Sebastian and finding all
of his quirkiness and my career so yeah
it ended up just being a great time well
we know you can sing so I know when the
singing that was the issue it stresses
me out though yeah I'd like yeah I don't
come on I don't self-identify that way
okay all right well I'm going to
identify you as a singer something about
you seems different I can't quite figure
it out she got legs you idiot and
Aquafina I know they they gave you a
little room to play right so they let
you kind of Improv what was in there
maybe that that you added a line or you
did a little more that we wouldn't have
known well like one one scene because
you know growing up Scuttle scuttles and
scuttle's energy is very memorable I
loved Scuttle growing up so it was kind
of I was kind of nervous to do like the
dingle hopper scene and I remember Rob
let me do a couple takes where like I
would just like kind of Riff Off of that
and I just I thought that that was
really cool because it's just like such
a like classic scene that yeah that you
could you're improving in this classic
scene but yeah it was fun why don't you
tell me something nice hey Scuttle I
like your hair I like the center part
because the side part looks like it's
receding a little bit I love you
Sebastian Jacob did you have any like
methods to get into flounders mindset
because like them all I mean flounder is
flounder I think has the heart of so
many people I guess just um just
watching the original because I did want
to embody that but um at the same time I
did I obviously wanted to make it my own
but obviously just having Rob there just
guiding you through it
um was was in amazing and he just knew
exactly what he's doing the whole time
so
um it was just really fun especially
because we did do like some improv I
mean it wasn't we did it was it was like
because it was like a uh what's cool
about it is that it is like a remake
shirt but we can we were still able to
go off script a little bit and just have
fun with it and really make it our own
can we talk about work
Ali Bailey because I know she like she's
nervous but she's
she's so beautiful
in this film where you guys all fans of
her music beforehand yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so what was that like you know kind
of bringing her into the aerial fold
because she was nervous she had never
really done this before you know when I
first met her in London when we did that
you know I really wanted to obviously
meet the new little Little Mermaid and I
remember just immediately she has such a
like she has such an amazing air about
her she's like so kind she's so like
personable she's humble
um and she's like very powerful as as
like like her I think her she has a
really powerful presence and um yeah it
was it was a dream she's a she's a dream
lead too as a co-star I think she's
really kind to people everybody kind of
felt that energy yeah she is amazing
within seconds like
I couldn't imagine anyone else in in
this live action where I think she just
she just killed it everything she just
did perfectly flawlessly it is like
breathtaking you sort of know that she
can she has this like vocal superpower
but as an actress too like she's just
she's incredibly powerful and just yeah
yeah it does that it's pretty much every
time she's on screen we were bringing
about some of the the things that that
she had to do yeah like going underwater
and stuff like yeah crazy um would you
call your of like one of lin-manuel
Miranda's bruises
oh I hope he doesn't see me that way no
because that's weird to talk to your boy
like what
you know what I'm saying no like you're
like speed dial First Call I don't know
I don't know I mean like working with
lady we are friends for so long at this
point you know our we worked on
freestyle Love Supreme together before
Hamilton so like I you know that time
Hamilton came along me and Linda been
friends for a decade so like I that's
just one of my many extraordinarily
talented friends who I feel very lucky
that occasionally wants to throw me in
something but so that was a long-winded
way of saying yes you're one of his Muse
I don't know I don't know I don't know
how that guy thinks you guys definitely
had like a shorthand this is super short
like the way that you guys communicate
especially even like when reading the
music that that you know that it was it
was crazy to witness the two of them
when we were working on Scuttle but
because Lynn was sort of writing a
Sebastian part for that in the airport
like on his way yes really and they had
called this like special rehearsal
because they were going to add these new
things right and like Lin's on the phone
and he was like I don't even have time
to I'm just gonna say it to you he just
like said it too I was like okay that's
exactly what happened yeah I was like uh
okay crazy yeah so having him you know
be a composer and producer on that what
was it like working because we know the
genius that that he is with everything
that he does that was really cool
working with him and just you know
caring what he had to say and I I think
that what the music like the new music
that he did in the film is so cool and
and so unique and then it also like
worked so well and and matches the theme
um it was it was awesome and he's also
just like a really really nice guy
really cool to work with and also like
it's just like my first time singing
like or doing anything musical so to
have like him there it was um was was
really really nice really yeah that
beautiful voice I know
I had no clue but you can sing sir maybe
not anymore because my voice has
definitely changed
yeah you guys did do this a couple of
years ago right I was like I think I
just turned 13. well I would say
congratulations because it's so well
done and I am one of those cynics who I
love my animated films I love my Disney
animated films and I usually don't want
anybody to touch them so I was going in
like okay what's gonna happen it's so so
good and y'all know like the Disney
fandom is a different type there's
levels to this right they're a different
type are you kind of ready for that you
all have great careers but are you ready
for that
um
you know if it's if you believe that
it's good and then and you love it and
you're a fan of it I think that you know
that's you you can you can withstand any
anything in any fandom but I think it's
because it has to it's it's so
intrinsically tied to people's
childhoods and and and and identities
you know so it's like
um I think that it with with that it's
it's just uh I hope that this will be a
part of people's childhoods too have you
all seen those videos of the little kids
especially little girls seeing Hallie it
was my first the best yeah incredible
that first trailer dropped in it yeah
yeah I mean that's my favorite I mean
those baby like I get emotional and I'm
like it's not even me well but it's just
those babies having this moment of
seeing themselves in a way in her it's
just it's it's wild thank you I think
you can't talk all day I know thank you
I appreciate
[Music]
thank you